there are a number of parallels between
Jared Kushner and his father-in-law
president Donald Trump like Trump
Kushner was born to a wealthy real
estate developer they were both born
just outside of the upper crust
Manhattan elite with Trump and queens
and Kushner in New Jersey and both were
handed the keys to their family's
lucrative businesses and then took the
opportunity to aggressively expand their
empires and now President Trump has made
Kushner his most trusted advisor in the
White House this is Jared Kushner Spath
from real estate Titan to media mogul to
the president's right-hand man the
soft-spoken 36 year old Kushner was born
in 1981 in Livingston New Jersey the son
of Charles Kushner a prominent real
estate developer and the grandson of
Rhea and Joseph Kushner both Holocaust
survivors Kushner graduated [ __ ] laude
from Harvard in 2003 with a bachelor's
in sociology he went on to earn his MBA
and juris doctorate from New York
University between Harvard and NYU Jared
took over Kushner companies after his
father Charles got into some legal
trouble he wound up doing that sooner
than expected I guess in his early 20s
and his father was convicted of trying
to set up his brother-in-law into the
criminal sort of scam he was prosecuted
by Chris Christie and so Jared counted
over
that's Devon Lennox I'm a staff writer
at Bloomberg Businessweek Jared didn't
just run the company but aggressively
expanded it Kushner shifted the focus of
his family business from New Jersey to
Manhattan purchasing almost 7 billion
dollars in property in less than a
decade mostly in New York City and he
didn't just buy real estate in 2006 he
also purchased the New York Observer for
what was widely reported to be 10
million dollars further cementing his
status and influence in New York now is
a meeting a power player when Jerry did
that you know overnight he went from
being son of a convicted felon to
inspiring for New York press Lords
something with a slur laundered the
family name by doing that but the prized
possession for Kushner company came in
2007 when Jared purchased 666 Fifth
Avenue for what was at the time the
highest price ever for a single building
in
York once Charles went to jail and they
said I had to reinvent the company to
reposition the company it was easy to do
just cross the river and do that to
Manhattan he sold all this property in
New Jersey and you know invested big
time in New York Kushner his next move
while having nothing to do with the
business was probably the most
influential decision in his life
he married Ivanka Trump in 2009 and when
the Kushner clan and Trump clan became
united they became front-page tabloid
fodder Kushner became a huge asset to
Trump throughout the campaign he used
his own network to help Trump set up
meetings with powerful donors and allies
and with a liaison between Trump and the
Jewish community even writing Trump's
APEC speech we will move the American
Embassy to the Eternals capital of the
Jewish people Jerusalem so when Trump
was elected and Kushner was named a
senior advisor not many were surprised
but ethics experts objected citing
nepotism laws created in the 60s from
JFK trying to make Robert Kennedy his
Attorney General so as Trump's
presidency continues to take shape
Kushner's taken over several diplomatic
and advisory roles in his administration
with no prior political experience every
move Kushner makes will be watched very
closely
you